is not
a word to be taken lightly there are
many powerful students in anime but
being powerful and being a badass are
two
different things what makes you a badass
is the perfect combination of the
uncompromising
the intimidating attitude and the
strength to always get better
even in the toughest situations having
said that let's take a look at some of
the most badass students in anime
we begin with the wildest and craziest
character on the list
yumiko from kakegurui yuma goes easily
the hottest chick on the list because
simply
she's the only chick on the list
yumiko's a transfer student in the elite
hyacal private academy
and although she looks graceful and
gorgeous she is a
freak she's a kakegurui someone who
finds pleasure in taking risks
it's basically like an adrenaline junkie
multiplied by bdsm
which is a term that i won't expand on
my dear young viewer
attractive smoother silk and silver
tongued yumiko
surely doesn't look like a 40 year old
man with a gambling addiction
yet still she's a natural-born gambler
nonetheless
of a failed knight is up now a boy is an
f rank apprentice knight who strives to
become a real mage knight
like most harem mcs he's got average
height dark brown hair and brown eyes
with a noble and caring personality
now when dealing with his women he gets
clumsy and dense with no experience
again like most haram main characters
then what is he doing on this list
you're probably asking
well the dude might be a worse when
dealing with women but he's no pushover
when he's dealing with opponents
ikki can learn others physical fighting
techniques by just looking at them
while fighting with what he calls blade
steel badass
he has an amazing observation ability
which allows him to grasp enemy stances
and learn their movements or know when
or where they're going to attack
badass he has a sister with a brother
complex badass no that's weird actually
that's weird
but if he's still not convinced yet then
just watch this clip of his epic
entrance when he fell
from the sky dodging bullets left and
right finishing the fight
with a badass stand
[Music]
classroom of the elite is an
inconspicuous student who's very poor at
communicating with other people
even if he wants to thus he tends to
isolate himself
his emotions are pretty hard to read he
intentionally received perfectly
intermediate scores on his entrance
examination since its academic
and athletic wise he's just an average
looking guy but don't let that lazy face
fool you
because the man can move with pretty
fast reflexes
impressive martial arts skills to
protect his women as well as his
classmates
add on top of that the big brain and
peepee energy and you get koji a swag
god
[Music]
our number seven is none other than ogre
from beelzebub
what do you need to be the parent of the
future demon lord
nothing too special just be a badass a
strong
arrogant badass that derives pleasure in
fighting and inflicting as much
pain as possible on others olga also
seems to take pleasure in tormenting
others
which are all good traits for either a
badass kid or a bully
however thankfully as the series
continued his personality began to alter
with each new trial and the friends he
encountered
as he became somewhat calmer but he
still retains his love for his cruelty
after all ogre is the father of the
future demon lord
next in our ten man list is bakugo from
my hero academia
by now i trust that most of you if not
all of you know the name bakugou
simply because most of the myhero
academia fans don't shy away from
mentioning him and simping over him
sure we could have gone with the chill
an even more popular choice todoroki
but we've decided to go with king
explosion murder
aka lord explosion murder aka gachan
because these hero title names are just
downright more awesome
than just a normie name and just like
how the hero title sounds
bakugo's a very aggressive person and
likes to bully the wimp
mc deku it is sad but after so many
episodes it becomes wholesome well
to me at least with its superiority
complex short fuse
big brain and big pp there's never a
dull moment when baku goes on screen
we're halfway there now fellas hope
you're still with us at number five
it's sheba from the irregular at magic
high school
believe it or not despite his look shiba
tatsuya is a first year student in
course two
of the first high school yep he might
look like he's pushing 30 but in reality
his anime reality shiva is a high school
student
sheba specializes in long range combat
and assassinations
however he remains almost unbeatable in
close combat
one of his powers is the ability to
analyze the enemy's magic
reading the activation sequences of the
spell as they're being built
thus it's easier for him to cast a
reverse ritual simultaneously
to prevent the enemy spell from going
off that's
like most of the other badass lads on
this list appears to have a very cold
personality
except when it comes to his friends and
sister
[Music]
is the most recent addition to the
badass student squad
he's the main protagonist of the 2020
show the misfit of
demon king academy two thousand years
ago arnos was the demon lord
he got reincarnated into the present
conveniently into an academy for
nurturing candidates for demon lords
voldegold can destroy humans elementals
and gods
which puts him this high on the list
also because of the fact he took shiro
emiya's dumb line
people died when their kid making it
somewhat good was enough to put him up
there
coming
[Music]
yes
and in third place is lelouch it's easy
to forget that lelouch is still a high
school student under all the massacres
and shenanigans he's done
but he's still a student nonetheless
lelouch was introduced in the first
episode of the series as a student at
ashford academy high school where he's a
member of his student council
once he obtained his guias lelouch
developed the power of absolute
obedience
this power allows him to take control of
someone else's mind through mere eye
contact
and subsequently bending them to his
will a brilliant thinker who's quite
talented at chess
lelouch is willing to do whatever it
takes to accomplish his goal
even if it means lying to his followers
and using people as bait for the
outcomes he desires however
he does have trouble putting those close
to him in harm's way for the sake of his
goal
gradually like a true future dictator
lelouch has come to embrace the fact
that he has to destroy
before reconstruction can occur even if
it means harming those he cares about
[Music]
okay now in second place is my personal
favorite character and show
karma from assassination classroom karma
is well known throughout the school for
his violent behavior and troublesome
attitude
he's skilled in fighting and tricks and
he prefers to stick to tricks and pranks
for assassinations rather than going
into full-out combat
he's manipulative and kind of sadist as
he takes great pleasure in harming
others
also karma excels at using weaponry when
fighting he becomes brutal and has no
problem in hurting people who threaten
him or any of his friends
in contrast karma's quite relaxed most
of the time as he occasionally skips out
on things he finds boring
all in all he's a chill redhead with a
short fuse
trigger it and you set yourself into a
world of pain
[Laughter]
[Music]
so from a red head boy to a white haired
boy
first place goes to accelerate it from a
certain scientific accelerator
nothing screams badass more than an edgy
teenager with white hair
accelerator's real name is unknown but
then again why do you need a lame ass
name like dolmar when you can have
accelerator as the first middle and last
name
like our last entry accelerator is a
sadistic boy
he has an ability called vector change a
form of telekinesis allowing him to
change the vector values of
anything he touches this ability allows
accelerator to perform feats such as
reversing the blood flow inside a
person's body
increasing the wind velocity around him
to create a massive plasma storm
and blocking sound his ability is
automatic which means that he must
consciously allow gravity to affect him
that his body blocks all ultraviolet
radiation resulting in his albino
appearance the white hair on the pale
skin
did you hear that the boy is so edgy to
the point gravity doesn't even mess with
him
now if this doesn't secure you the
number one spot then i don't know what
will
and with that being said i hope you
enjoyed this video
if you did then don't shy away from
giving it a thumbs up if you didn't then
just
keep that thumbs down to yourself don't
worry about that also no need to say but
i will say it anyway
feel free to list your favorite badass
students in the comments section
and finally fellas share as well as
subscribe because that's how we grow
until next time